chacun constate qu'il y a à améliorer la
police nationale de son fonctionnement
il y a derrière la police nationale des
femmes des hommes qui ont mis beaucoup
d'énergie beaucoup de vie personnelle
beaucoup de sentiments dans leur métier
qui est un métier à une énorme pression
grosse identité et moi je pense que
l'une des raisons principales pour
lequel une partie et je terminerai
là-dessus
une partie des agents le conteste c'est
parce que justement ils ont peur de
perdre cette identité et qui sont
parfois une vocation d'une vie quand on
est policier d'après judiciaire c'est
vocation d'une vie on a tous sacrifié
parfois pour ça et je le comprends très
bien et mon travail et c'est avec nous
faisons ensemble c'est évidemment
essayer de les rassurer après madame
la comparaison est à la forme des
retraites me paraît étonnante sauf pour
le le
l'envie de faire de la politique
absolument parce que il y a 250 000
policiers
je crois que si vous les interrogez
l'immense majorité des policiers que
pour rencontrer tous les jours non
seulement ne conteste pas mais approuve
une réforme qu'ils attendent depuis très
longtemps notamment les policiers dit de
sécurité publique ce que nous
rencontrons c'est choisir lorsque nous
rentrons dans un dans un commissariat de
police
ceux qui comptait c'est une partie de la
police une partie non mais c'est une
réforme de la police nationale ceci
j'essaie de vous convaincre depuis tout
à l'heure c'est pas une réforme de la
police judiciaire c'est toute la police
nationale qui est concernée aujourd'hui
il y a
plein de gens de la sécurité publique
qui sont aussi bousculés dans leurs
habitudes plein de gens de la PAF qui
sont bousculés dans leurs habitudes il y
a une partie qui pose un certain nombre
de questions que évidemment il faut y
apporter des réponses et j'ai eu
l'occasion de dire que le modèle qui est
celui sur lequel nous allons aller c'est
un modèle type sur darborie nationale
qui fonctionne déjà aussi outils
préfecture de police qui fonctionne déjà
ainsi donc moi ma porte évidemment est
toujours ouverte j'ai un énorme respect
pour y compris ceux qui ont des opinions
divergentes sur ce que nous proposons je
crois qu'on a mis déjà beaucoup de
compromis on va entendre ce qu'on va
dire vos rapporteurs comme ceux de
l'Assemblée nationale j'ai déjà dit que
je prenais l'intégralité des
propositions des inspections y compris
ceux de la justice et surtout moi je
vais écouter désormais les relations
syndicales dans les sources syndicales
ce sont jamais exprimées jusqu'à présent
à peut-être devant vous
monsieur le rapporteur madame leur
rapporteur mais pas de pas parce qu'ils
avaient pas le projet donc maintenant
ils l'ont et donc on va la demander en
fonction de ses amendements évidemment
j'en prendrai une très grande partie je
je pense de ce que les premiers échanges
que j'ai pu avoir avec eux j'aurai
l'occasion de montrer que je non
seulement j'écoute mais j'entends